MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this video, we
talk about stability
and, the opposite of stability,
the decays of nuclei.
OK, so let's look
at this diagram
first, which shows the
number of protons--
the number of protons and
the number of neutrons here.
And you find that
the stable elements
sit in this so-called
Valley of Stability.
So there's a certain part of
our nuclei which are stable.
This valley follows directly
out of the discussion
of the binding energy, where
you can calculate the optimal Z
value such that the
mass is minimal.
It's about A half in this
area here at low masses,
and about 40% of A the higher
part-- at high value of mass.
We already discussed that the
binding energy has this form
here, with a maximum
around the mass of iron,
which is like somewhere here--
50 some.
OK, so it's
energetically favorable
for some unstable
nuclei to break apart
in so-called fission processes.
And it's also
energetically favorable
to fuse together
to create energy.
And we'll talk about the
applications of those processes
later on.
But for now, we
want to just look
at a radioactive nuclide, which
can decay in various ways.
And so the first, most prominent
decays we want to discuss
here-- and then we'll
follow up a little later--
is an alpha decay,
which is splitting up--
a mother particle splits up
into daughter particle nuclei
and helium-- which is
an alpha particle--
or the emission of electrons,
positrons, or the capture of
electrons as well.
It is also possible,
but rather rare,
that a nuclei just spits out a
proton, or spits out a neutron.
So this is possible,
but it's rather rare.
All right, so let's look
at the alpha decay first.
As I said, we start from a
rather large, heavy nuclei.
And it seems possible
for it to spit out
helium or an alpha particle.
So the first thing we want to--
the view we want to have here
is of the potential in which
the alpha particle sits.
So the alpha particle
sees a really deep well
of the nuclear potential.
And it also sees this
boundary here, this barrier,
of the Coulomb potential.
So for the alpha
particle to be emitted,
it needs to break through
this Coulomb potential here.
And you can calculate the
likelihood using quantum
mechanics-- the quantum
tunneling likelihood--
in order to figure
out how stable
an individual particle is.
Here, I just wanted
to show you something.
This plot here shows you the
lifetime of an unstable nuclei,
for various sorts, as a
function of the energy.
And what you see here is it's
very strong energy dependent.
This is a logarithmic plot.
And what you see is
the lifetime seems
to be rather, rather short
when the emitted particle has
a lot of energy.
And that can be explained by
this plot here very easily.
In order for this particle--
the energy of this particle,
when it goes here, is dependent
on where this particle sits
in this potential, right?
So particles which sit
at very high values here
will have a high likelihood to
tunnel through this barrier,
and therefore a short lifetime.
Hence, this particle
has a lot of energy
after it's been emitted.
So we see lifetimes in the
range of 10 nanoseconds to 10
to the 17 years
for some examples.
So there's this huge
variation depending
on where the alpha particle
sits in this potential.
We can have a discussion
of the energetics involved.
And we use our very same
formula for the binding energy.
So you write this down
here, including your helium
here, and then just
figuring out what
are the contribution of
the individual terms.
And since we observe
experimentally
alpha decays only for heavy
particles, in this discussion
here, we can assume that
Z is approximately 0.041
times the mass number.
And so the energy of the
emitted alpha particle for this
to be able to occur
has to be positive.
And so we find this to be
possible for A values starting
from about 150.
Experimentally, you
observe this to start
happening at about 200.
All right, the next thought we
want to discuss is beta decay.
So this is shown in this
diagram here, where--
starting from carbon-14
decays, for example--
carbon-14, you will see
this in the next recitation,
is very useful probe in
order to date living things,
and date when they were
not living anymore.
And you will discuss why and
how you can actually do this.
But for now, carbon-14
can decay via beta decay.
And what you find is
nitrogen, an anti-electron,
and an electron.
This is a beta decay,
or beta minus decay.
And using our particle
physics discussion,
we can easily understand this.
The neutron is transformed
into a proton via electroweak
processes with a W.
The electron comes out,
the anti-neutrino comes out.
And similarly, we can
look at carbon-10 here.
Into boron is a
neutrino and a positron.
And again here, we have
a W plus in the decay.
So now, we can, again,
use our binding energy
in order to understand this.
So what we want to do here,
for constant mass numbers,
you want to plot the binding
energy for the individual atoms
or nuclei.
And so if you do this for odd
A, those as where the pairing
term doesn't contribute, you
find this nice quadratic term.
And you can find beta decays in
each of those instances here.
For A even, you have the
question whether or not
Z is odd or N is odd--
oh sorry, Z and N are
odd, or Z and N are even.
So you have two
quadratic functions here.
And you find the beta decay
between one and the other.
And so that's interesting
you find those decays chains,
based on where you
start in the chain,
you have the possibility
to go back and forth.
And because of the
even and odd pattern,
the lifetime of the decay
can vary quite tremendously
between those individual states.
Last but not least,
election capture--
if you have a very
massive nuclei and atom,
and the electrons-- you know,
thinking about a cloud around
this--
some of the electrons can
come very, very close,
and be captured into the nuclei.
And you find this here.
The time direction
goes up, proton
captures via the
weak interaction.
The electron becomes a
neutron and emits a neutrino.
And an example is the electron
capture of krypton into boron.
All right, so we start to get
some sort of understanding
of nuclear decays.
We find this Valley
of Stability here.
We find, in a large
range for lower numbers
of Z, beta decays.
For higher numbers of Z,
we find beta plus decays.
And for very heavy nuclei,
we find alpha decays.
Proton decays, seen at
the very boundary here,
and nuclear fission processes
where the nuclei spontaneously
breaks up, we haven't
discussed in detail.
But you can think about
them very similarly
to the alpha decay.
As you already kind
of probably saw
from the discussion
of the beta decay,
it's possible to have
rather long decay chains.
So you start from
radioactive nuclei,
which then decays, and
decays, and decays, and decays
in those kind of chains.
So this is two examples
here-- the thorium chain
and the uranium chain--
creating all kinds of
other new elements.
And on the uranium chain,
it's very interesting
to say uranium is
part of our core.
If you build a house
and you build--
if you build-- the
foundation is concrete,
you probably have
some uranium in there,
which then, in this decay
chain, generates radium.
And therefore, if you build
a house with concrete,
you want to have a measure to
get rid of the radium which
is just floating around.
All right, so this
is it for now.
We continue the discussion with
more detailed understanding,
or detailed discussion,
on how those decay
processes are possible, and
what we can learn from them.